I have friends who grew up very liberal
and they specifically seek out
Progressive churches so having a female
priest is a way to say like hello it's
us we have we are part of the left
ideology but I think ultimately it is a
a sign that they are selling their
theology to be a part of culture well
you'll hear often I know I heard this a
lot when I was going to Anglican
Episcopalian churches uh was that you
know Church attendance is down so we
have to find a way to appeal to the
young people and so you know what a
great idea is we'll put up our rainbow
flag and we'll get we'll get a lady
priest
did you ever see the video of them the
church that like painted the rainbow
everywhere and then that one guy came by
as she was painting the room he was like
what are you doing like this is a
disgrace like you call yourself a
Christian like tell me where it says
this is allowed in the Bible yeah and
she couldn't tell them and then did you
know explain that the rainbow is God's
covenant you know it's meant for
outside your church but still you know
you know rainbow back